اعلن حزب الله ان مقاتليه استهدفوا موقع
المطل العسكري الاسرائيلي قباله القطاع
الشرقي من جنوبي لبنان وحققوا اصابات
مؤكده وفد مراسل الجزيره بان طائرات
ومسيرات اسرائيليه شنت غارات على منطقه
البونه ومحيط بلدتي مارون الراس وعلم
الشعب كما استهدفت محيط بلدات الخيام وكفر
كلا وحولا ويارونق الحزب اعلن امس تنفيذه
ثلاثه هجمات ضد القوات الاسرائيليه منها
استهداف من ين للقبه الحديديه شماليه
مستوطنه كابري واطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
مستوطنه كريات شمونه وقال الحزب ان اطلاق
الصواريخ جاء ردا على استهداف الجيش
الاسرائيلي لمراسم تشييع احد مقاتليه
بصاروخ في بلده عيت
الشعب معنا من الجليل الاعلى مراسله
الجزيره فاطمه خميسه ومعنا من مرجعيون
جنوبيه لبنان ايهاب العقدي مرحبا بكما
ابدا معك فاطمه
والاجواء هنالك حيث انت تحديدا ما يعلنه
الجيش حول ما يصل اليه من مسيرات
واستهداف نعم يعني الاحداث جدا متسارعه
ومتتاليه نتحدث عن دوي صفارات الانذار
لاكثر من سته مرات خاصه في الدقائق
الاخيره كان هنالك دوي متواصل لسفارات
الانذار في الجليل الاعلى وايضا في الجليل
الغربي بعد رصد دخول وتسلل مسيرات من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه مناطق متفرقه في الجليل
الاعلى والجليل الغربي وكان هنالك ايضا
تخوفات من شن حزب الله هجوم مزدوج اي يشمل
الصواريخ المضاده للدروع وايضا يشمل
المسيرات المفخخه لذلك كان هنالك اعلان عن
اعتراض الدفاعات الجويه لمسيره في سهل
الحولي في الجليل الاعلى وايضا رصد اطلاق
لقذائف وصواريخ مضاده للدروع في المطل
تحديد اي كان هنالك صاروخ مضاد الدروع
اطلق باتجاه موقع عسكري الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن عن رصد هذا الصاروخ ولم يقم بالاعلان
عن وجود اصابات او اضرار كما انه قابل قال
انه استهدف خليه مسلحه تابعه لحزب الله
كانت بالقرب من بلده حنيته التي تبعد فقط
سته كيلومترات عن ال الحدود اللبنانيه وان
استهدف هذه الخليه عبر مسيره اسرائيليه
لاحباط محاوله اطلاق ذائف واطلاق صواريخ
مضاده للدروع باتجاه الاراضي الاسرائيليه
هنالك تحركات على المستوى الميداني جدا
متسارعه في الساعات الاخيره رغم ان
البارحه مثلا كان هنالك عمليات جدا محدوده
لحزب الله نتحدث عن اطلاق صواريخ ثلاثه
الصواريخ تحديدا باتجاه بلده كريات شموه
والتي سقطت في وسط المدينه وتسببت باضرار
جدا كبيره في الممتلكات العامه وايضا كان
هنك اصابه لمنزل بشكل مباشر لذلك يعني كان
كان من المتوقع ان تشهد اليوم والجبهه
الشماليه تطورات وحده في التطورات وكما
نعلم انه يعني القصف المتبادل ما بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي وما بين حزب الله لازال
قائم رغم دخول هذه الحرب يوم ال7 معنا
ايهاب اذا هل هذه الوتيره مختلفه
ومرتفعه من لبنان عن الامس على
الاقل
بالامس حصل التطور الخطير بالنسبه
لاستهداف الجانب
الاسرائيلي منزلا في عي الشعب عند تشييع
جنازه لاحد مقاتلي حزب الله لكن الواضح ان
هذا اليوم عاد الى القواعد السابقه من حيث
الاستهدافات العسكريه من جانب حزب الله
للجانب الاسرائيلي والرد الاسرائيلي على
مكان ما يشتبه بانها هجمات لحزب الله في
الاماكن التي استهدفها بالمدفعيه و و
بالطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اليوم استعان بالطائرات
الحربيه وبمسي لشان سلسله من الغرات على
القطاعين الغربي والاوسط القطاع الغربي
كانت استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بسلسله غرات التي قامت بالقاء
عدد من الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه الناقوره
واللبونه ايضا المسيرات استهدفت هدفا في
منطقه علم الشعب وايضا في مارون الراس
وكلها قرى محاذ للشريط الحدودي المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه شاركت ايضا في عمليات القصف
منذ بعض الوقت هناك قصف على بلده محيط
بلده بليده في القطاع الاوسط وكان هناك
قصف ايضا على على عدد من الاماكن القريبه
من الحدود في القطاع الشرقي حزب الله شن
حتى الان عمليه واحده وكان هناك اطلاق سته
صواريخ في اتجاه الجليل الاعلى من اسرائيل
نعم ايهاب العقد مرجعيون اشكر ايضا فاطمه
خسي شكرا جزيلا
لكما